the president is making major headlines
tonight declaring that there is no
evidence of collusion and did he do that
sit down under oath with the Special
Counsel again let me play this for you
we'll get reaction from judge Jeanine
[Music]
[Music]
while the keywords are subject to my
lawyers now the president's attorney Ty
Cobb also weighing in telling the New
York Times Tonight quote he's ready to
meet with them but he will be guided by
the advice of his personal counsel so
should the president sit down with
robert muller joining us now with more
reaction to that she's the host of
justice she also fills in on this show
she's also a very nice person and a
great lawyer how are you I'm fine thanks
okay the answer to your question is very
simple the president absolutely should
not sit down he should not agree to do
it but look you and I both know the
president he says there is no collusion
there isn't any I admire him wanting to
do it and but you know what I don't
believe that his lawyers have agreed
that he will do it and he said it'll be
subject to the lawyers but let me tell
you why Sean number one why should he
answer questions about the firing of
Comey if he has a constitutional right
to fire him and number two it the way he
shouldn't that be his answer if in fact
he goes yes but what they it's never
gonna end
I know federal prosecutors aren't going
to go I gotta stop you before you put it
your point no no this is important so
I've actually talked to my friends that
are attorneys right okay and they say to
me I said I brought this scenario of
what if I'm being interviewed by these
people he goes you say no and then you
got to be willing to sit there yep and
I'm used to it my life no dead air ever
but I will tell you I'd be able to do
that but we know President Trump he's
gonna say no and I'll tell you why and
why and why and he's going to go on and
on and he's gonna talk about this a trap
that it is a trap there's no question
that's what the feds do and we already
know that they're biased but the second
reason is he only needs to answer
questions about crimes if it's not a
crime to fire Jim Comey
and what crime are we talking about
collusion Russian collusion is not a
crime
ergo he doesn't need to appear and what
they're going to do is they're going to
continue to bring witnesses before the
grand jury
squeeze them to try to implicate him and
make him seem like a liar it is
ridiculous to go before it's the highest
process it's like poor general Flynn I
mean they already knew his answers cuz
they illegally surveilled unmask they
didn't minimize and then they league for
intelligence he walked into a perjury
trap because they knew everything he
said that's scary by the way in terms of
unreasonable search and seizure no
warrants and it never should have
happened
the problem here is they don't like this
president look at this team that Robert
Muller put together is that fair struck
Weissman their backgrounds they're a
true Weissman is a guide that withheld
exculpatory evidence well he has a
terrible reputation as a prosecutor the
courts know it the Department of Justice
knows it but this is the same Department
of Justice that has allowed all the
things that you've talked about for the
last several months here is a bottom
line it's our Justice Department it's
our FBI you stop it Muller pushes or how
do you stop executive privilege you go
to the Supreme Court what do you do well
certainly there's executive privilege
you don't have to go before them this is
more political reason than it is a legal
reason and that's why the president's
saying sure I'll do it do you think like
I do
I don't trust Muller based on who he's
appointed and all that's gone on I think
Muller is out for blood Muller is not
only out for blood he's out to save his
own butt and I'll tell you because of
all the revelations because he is the
person who should be investigated Jim
Comey should be investigated all of
these guys struck McCabe why they
getting a paycheck why is my tax payers
money paying for them my dollars these
people need to be taken out in cuffs
I've said it before Shawn this is not
our Justice Department this is a bunch
of arrogant condescending people who
think they know better than we do you've
been on it the whole time the whole time
Shawn and you've been on it as well
judge glad to see you